diversity obviously is a conversation
people are having these days but look
jeffrey tambor one for transparent
orange is the new black one it's got a
trans character on that show Alicia
vikander for the Danish girl I mean it
seems like the acceptance reach is
broadening I have a transgender sister
and that to me is a huge huge step in
the right direction that that we're
recognizing on the beautiful community
that we are recognizing them accepting
and the conversations are starting and
for me to have someone like Jeffrey up
there and talking about the issues
continuously Laverne doing the same
thing people are writing it it's a
beautiful thing and I couldn't be more
proud to be part of a show that kind of
like started this whole thing with this
woman right here I just got really come
up well I mean you know I love you guys
so much um I can't believe I'm here
you know I I dreamed about this for a
very long time and I know a lot of
people like me are out there dreaming
and so often things don't happen there's
so much effed up stuff happening in the
world right now so many of us are just
struggling to survive and I've been
there um
and that's what you're so good at what
you do because it's life Xperia and I
edit and it just feels great to share
this with you and and just we've just
shared so many moments over the years
and it just I don't know she's cool
it's come full circle baby